quantum computing の重要性は、過小評価されると同時に
過大に誇張されてもいます。
従来のコンピューターに取って代わるわけではありませんが、
quantum のイノベーションは新しい computing パラダイムを示しています。
Quantum computer は現在の computing
インフラと連携して、これまで
非現実的または不可能と思われていた複雑な問題を解決できます。
これはパラダイムシフトをもたらしえます。
例えば、大きな数を素因数分解することの難しさは、
現代の暗号技術の基盤となっています。
現代の公開鍵暗号で使われる数のサイズでは、
秘密鍵暗号のこの計算には、
最速の従来型コンピューターで 3000 兆年以上かかります。
大規模な quantum computer が
Shor のアルゴリズムを使えば、この計算は数秒で完了する可能性があります。
このような複雑な問題はあらゆる産業に存在します。
quantum computing の潜在的な応用範囲は
非常に広大です。
Quantum computer はすでに大型化・高性能化が進んでおり、
より高度な問題に取り組むため
さらに複雑な課題への挑戦を目指しています。
2016 年以来、IBM は quantum computer を
楽譜のようなグラフィカルインターフェースを備えたウェブサイトを通じて
一般公開しています。
また、ソフトウェア開発キット Qiskit も提供しており、
ユーザーが quantum computer をプログラムできます。
企業の内外を問わず、科学者たちが
実験を行っています。
同様のポータルを通じて。化学や
機械学習の問題へのアプローチを探求しながら、
どのような問いを問えるか
そしてその問いをどのように組み立てるかを
技術がさらに進歩した際に向けて考えています。今こそ、
ビジネスリーダーが quantum に向けて
準備を整える絶好の機会です。この根本的に新しい技術を
実験し拡大する条件が整っています。
この変革的な転換の最前線に
立つことを目指す組織は、
競争上の優位性を手にするでしょう。このトレーニングは
あなたの quantum ジャーニーを始める準備を整えます。